robbing after doing television and film
for years you've decided to write a book
and you tell us about the book why you
wrote it yes um my husband who's a
cinematographer was invited back to his
alma mater to help the senior thesis
students with their films and to advise
them and to kind of walk them through
things and so he said hey throw in an
extra ticket my wife will talk to the
theater department you know so so we did
and I'm sitting at my mother-in-law's
you know and I took my reel back and I'm
sitting there the night before we're
supposed to talk and I thought we've all
just been through you know theater
history and stagecraft and all of these
sorts of things you know what do I have
to share with them that they haven't
just been steeped in for the last you
know four years and and I thought I can
tell them what it's like to actually
live the life of an artist what that
really entails the day-to-day stuff that
helps sustain you as you go forward so I
began writing the book on my
mother-in-law's dining room table and
that became the basis of my talk to the
students the next day and then it just
evolved into that and a couple years
later I had the book which I just have a
way to show it
yes there are bruising Ives dude it's a
survivors Guide to Hollywood how to play
the game without losing your soul I
loved the cover thank you thank you very
much mhm
and so yeah so I'm and it's it's gotten
wonderful reviews and and the thing that
I like the most about it I think is that
it applies I've gotten housewives house
painters people who aren't in this
business at all people in the computer
business from all over who have read the
book who say this is just a book about
life this is just a good bunch of
information about how to be happy and to
to just another perspective on how to
live your life it's sort of it's
obviously predicated on my experiences
here but it applies to everything I'm as
a matter of fact I'm working on a
one-woman show now a friend
mine came to me and said you need to do
a one-woman show a rat you know kind of
the book is an anchor but expanding it a
bit and I'm gonna call it a survivor's
guide to Hollywood in other strange
places because there are strange places
everywhere and so yeah so it applies to
it all walks of life and that I think
was my chief surprise and delight when I
when people started buying it and
reading it and reviewing it so it's
interesting you say about you know being
happy because I think a lot of people
and and I haven't achieved success that
I want to achieve but I've heard from
others I think forget which interview I
heard from someone that once you
supposedly reached this like imaginary
level all your problems are gonna
disappear and the person said no that's
when they really start to come out
because you you you think that once this
certain levels achieved that you're
going to just it's gonna be like green
lights and you know just yes everywhere
and you're never gonna feel a down day
no see that's the why I say live your
life in between the jobs and the moments
because that's the only life you really
have you know there's always going to be
someone on the ladder on a rung on the
ladder ahead of you you know because you
started when you started then they
started when they started and there's
going you know they're going to there's
always going to be somebody ahead of you
so you you never reached the point
because it's it's an evolution our lives
all our lives are evolving at all times
if you're paying any attention and if
you are invested in your life you know
psychologically and emotionally and
metaphysically you're growing right from
the people that are artists that have
read your book
what's the chapter or what part it
really stands out to them do you think
for from the feedback you've received
well I've gotten feedback on all of it
which is lovely in in the middle of the
book there little takeaway is little
yellow highlighted passages that kind of
have the advice for you and and one of
the things that someone has told me is
the idea of celebrating really struck
home with them and that
we we always wait - I know I'm speak
sometimes in these broad brushstrokes we
always do this or everyone does this and
I hope you know I'm just one has a
tendency sure yeah you celebrate
birthdays and holidays but you don't
celebrate that you just got a parking
space you don't celebrate that you just
a residual check came in right no you
don't celebrate that oh we just had this
lovely day together you know and and I
think we have to celebrate everything
because as Napoleon said in victory you
deserve champagne in defeat you need it
some of my celebrations have involved a
glass of champagne usually after I've
stunk up the room in a tone addition or
something like well that was terrible
alright champagne we have to do
something to sort of counterbalance but
but other than that we should celebrate
our lives you know I mean I when I was a
little girl I loved I don't know why but
I'm a because the grown-ups all the
people in the theater that my parents
were around and I was around and came
home and there were always parties at
her house there was always you know a
big pot of chili or something more
expensive depending upon how well we
were doing at the time but and people
together and people breaking bread and
having a drink and and and I just I was
couldn't wait for to be grown-up enough
to make that happen in my own life and
so giving party someone once asked me if
you could live whatever life you wanted
to live what would it be and now at this
stage in my life it would be to travel
to give parties and to do a fabulous
play once a year that sounds nice I
would love to do that and someone said
to me so why don't you do it and I
thought good question so yeah and and so
the celebration this she said this one
reader of the book said she loved the
idea of celebration and I encourage
everyone to do that you don't have to
wait for the big things celebrate the
little things because that's what's
happening now
and as you said you know people wait
when I get to the place that magical
place where everything is perfect and
I'm always in demand and there's nothing
No
all of your insecurities go with you no
matter how famous or rich you are you
know do people like me because I'm
famous and rich can be a new one if you
need a new insecurity and most of us
have plenty of our own but you know you
can add new ones in but there's never
there isn't an end because we're growing
all the time there's not a I suppose
there's a place when I make people could
say when I make this much money then I
will begin to live the life I want but
if you're not living some version of the
life you want right now you're not
living mmm the John Lennon quote what is
it life happens while you're making
other busy yeah yeah that's wonderful
yeah and you know so that and then
giving yourself credit for things that
you accomplished that is something that
people have said to me my niece is
working with some women who are young
actresses just come to Hollywood and
she's handed my book out to a couple of
them and one of the girls came back to
her and said I took your aunt's advice
and I am giving myself credit for all of
I'm sending out my picture and resume
and giving myself credit for that's my
work today I went to work today I'm
looking for agents and that's putting in
that's not the drudgery that's the job
you know so you do that and you give
yourself credit for having sent out
three envelopes today have a celebration
you know and when you get a job you by
your friends around a drinks I know I
talk about drinking a lot don't I but
it's sort of the epitome of a little
celebration sure you know what do you
say to people though that are scared to
be a beat because maybe in their lives
another shoe drops once that you know
there's start listening for the other
shoe guess what you're gonna get one you
know it's like when you leave the house
today III are when I have left the house
sometimes if I'm not you know listen I'm
not Rebecca of Sunnybrook farm I get
pissed off too and their little
annoyances of
of life get to me occasionally but I
notice that when I go if I start
swearing at the first idiot driver you
know doesn't pay attention on the road I
am astonished at how quickly a lot of
other idiots show up you know you call
that to you there's a metaphysical
quality of that that if you're afraid to
do something exciting or fun because
you're afraid it's not gonna work out
well it won't it won't work out in one
of two ways it won't work out because
you didn't even bother to try so that's
not going to work out or it's not going
to work out because you pronounced not
working out in this upon it you know and
and if you it's there's another I don't
know if this is biblical or not but
there is a there to that I like a lot
one of them is life and death is in the
power of the tongue
I think that is from the Bible I don't
know chapter or verse and the other one
is what you fear comes upon you and I
don't know whether that's a biblical
attribution or not but but those two
things are very true you know you keep
pronouncing that oh I don't have enough
money for the rent this month I don't
have enough money oh my god what am I
going to do about the rent this month
well when the rent comes due you're
likely not to have what you need you
know I one time when I was I didn't have
enough money for the rent I had $25 in
my pocket and I and I so a girlfriend
came over and I said let's go have a
margarita and I bought it and two days
later I had a job that paid the rent for
three months
Wow you know I mean you have to you have
to step out in faith you know that the
things that you're going to that you'll
have what it is that you need that
things will be provided for of course
with the caveat that you don't rent a
Malibu mansion that you don't lease a
fancy car so you look good when you
arrive at your audition which is stupid
because you park in the street or
somewhere the casting person isn't going
to see you anyway it's another matter
and if you need a car to make you feel
good about yourself then this is not the
business you should be in
you